the difference between social science
and reading tea leads is one of
perspective
social science assumes a material world
reading tea leaves and horoscopes and
crystal balls and whatever else you want
to look at
assumes a spiritual world neither of
those things
will actually give you the power to
predict the future
certainly not over the long run and the
world is obviously
spiritual so this is my other beyond the
cookie poll this is my other
favorite piece of social science that
that
because of the spiritual humor of the
world tells us something
karen's support biden dicks support
trump
i'm not using any slurs i'm not using
any kind of foul language
that is a scientific fact karen's
women named karen tend to support joe
biden
and men named richard tend to support
donald trump
the new york times has been conducting
polls with siena college for two months
now
to look at how people with certain names
vote
so if you if you look here you've got
the the most common
name the most likely popular name to
support biden
all the way down there is karen
michael is up up toward the trump line
of things michaels tend to support trump
and then richard dick most likely
popular name to support
donald trump now you can look a little
more closely at this
and find out that there are a few women
who are more likely to support trump
than biden
linda jennifer nancy those are women
who will are more likely to vote for
trump there is one man who's 50 50.
that's
joseph and then all and christopher too
also 50 50.
and then all the rest of the pro-biden
people
so so every single pro-biden name
is a woman
which i guess should make sense
tends to be the k and some women then
vote for
trump because married women tend to vote
republican and single women tend to vote
democrat so we need we need more nancies
in the world
we need more jennifers we need more
lindas
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
you